はい よろしくお願いします
はい これからお経の時間になりますかね
偉大なる人の役に立つためには
ということで 今日はアーナンダ尊者のお話になります
で アーナンダ長老 あまりこのアーナンダマハーテーラとかあんまり使わないんですけど
もう仏教の歴史ではとても親しみを感じる
もうあまりにもたくさん名前使っているアーナンダ長老なんですね
で とても尊敬されている理由がたくさんございまして
本当はあの時間の時間では
もう何とかして省略しようかなと思ったんですけど
あまりにもデータがありすぎて
で 大変難しかったんです
世の中でね 人々を褒める時は
もうやっと見つけて 何か一言葉見つけてもう褒め称えるだけの世界ですからね
顕微鏡が必要になるんですね
人はもう貶したくはないんだからね
褒めたいんですよ で そういう世界でね
アーナンダ尊者の場合は逆に
顕微鏡ではダメなんです
全部まとめて小さく見える望遠鏡みたいなものでも足らないぐらい
ものすごい大量に特に飛んでいる
溢れている方なんです
エラーが入ってます えーと
アーナンダ尊者の特色は
このタイトル  5つ持ってます
タイトルと言うんですか？何て言いますかね
敬語でもないんですね
称号 称号ですかね 称号というか
まあ一応いろいろ位ですね
で これ 誰から？誰か大学からもらったものではないんです
偉大なるお釈迦様は 正学者であるお釈迦様が称号を与えるんです
それぞれの能力に対して
仏弟子たちにお釈迦様がまるまる第一というタイトルを与えるんです
この第一っていうのがもう大事なんです
もう人間の中でそこを乗り越える
その能力を乗り越える人はいませんという意味なんです
ですから お釈迦様に称号をもらうということは
まあ相当大変なことで
で 長い間修行して 輪廻の中でもパーラミタ完成して
その能力を向上した方々だけもらうもので
阿羅漢になっていることと
誰よりも優れた特別な能力があることが条件ですね
で これは出家の場合なんですね
出家比丘たちも比丘尼たちも称号をもらったんです
あまりサービスはなかったんです
しかし やっぱり悟りに達していないと
完全に阿羅漢になっていないと得られない
阿羅漢になるのは ほとんどの出家者がね
当時は阿羅漢になっていましたから
ただそれだけではダメですよ
人間と比較すると桁違い
何かの能力があってほしいということで
それで我々何か学ぶことで
人間っていうのは何でもできるようにならなくても結構ですよ
何か一つの能力さえあれば
この世の中でうまく生きていられます
問題はこの仏教のこの言葉から見れば
しかし 基本的な条件 出家の場合は阿羅漢になっていること
阿羅漢になっていて それは基本条件で
その上何か能力があると
それは出家世界で では
皆様の世界から考えると
我々の俗世間から考えるとどうなるのかというと
人間が何か能力があれば
何か一つで十分です そんな大したことはなく
ほんの小さな能力を一つ身につけば
それで生きているためには十分なんですが
基本的な能力もあります
それは人格なんです 人格者でなければ
どんな能力があっても意味がないんです
犯罪者になるんです あるいは自己破壊になるんです
最近のニュースでいえば
小室さんという優秀なすごい能力ある音楽家がいて
その能力には何の疑問も疑いもなし
もう抜群な能力を持っていて
しかし 人間として この社会の中で
生きている能力はなかったんですね
そこで失敗してしまうんですね
かわいそうですよ あの天才的な音楽の才能とともに
人間としてもうちょっとまとめでいたならば
いかに幸福に生きていられるのかということでしょ
だから世の中でそれすごい気をつけた方が良い
仏教が皆様に言う一つのポイントなんです
何々博士とか そんなもので自慢する前に
あんた人間でしょうかと
そこはまず大事なんです
で 天才的な能力を持っているね
科学者の方々いるでしょうに
しかし 彼らが人類の幸福のためではなくて
人類を破壊するために自分の研究能力を使ったりする
だからもう 世界のためにはなりません
ノーベル平和賞 ノーベル賞をあげる場合は
やはり人類に貢献しているのかということをちょっと調べるポイントなんですけど
裏では別なことを調べますけどね
で 表に出している理由は
人類に貢献しているのかということなんですね
そういうことだから 私たちにはほんの少々の能力があるかもしれませんし
そんな大胆なことできなくて結構です
ほんの少々の能力さえあれば
何でもいいんですよ 整理するとができるとかね
文字は書けるとか 美しく
もう何でもいいんですよ
それほど大変な能力というものも必要じゃありません
あるいは会話が上手とか
で それと同時に人間であること
立派な それでは生きていられます
性格がすごい良い性格だったら
社会がその人を持っている
あの少々の能力を買うんですよ
そこを頼むんで これやってくださいと
そういうことで この最初に我々に仏教が言っているポイントはそれなんです
何か才能 何か能力を持っただけでは役に立ちませんよと
基本的には人格ができていないとダメですね
そういうわけで お釈迦様がタイトルを与える場合は
それは世間に証明して見せたんです
阿羅漢なら誰でもということはないんです
合格者合格者にはするんだけど
合格者たち その中でも有名なのは人の偉大なる弟子たちがいて
それぞれすごい能力を持っていたんですね
それでみんな一つ か称号をもらってないんです
せいぜい言えばサーリプッタ尊者
目連尊者があの お釈迦様の一番トップの弟子二人という
そのアッガアッガサーヴァコ
弟子の一番トップというあって
それからもう一つ サーリプッタ尊者が知恵第一人者
サーリプッタ尊者の知恵は誰も人間は敵わないんです
神々も敵わないんです
目連尊者は人数ですね
サマーディ瞑想の一人者
瞑想能力サマーディ能力では
目連尊者には誰も敵わない
サーリプッタ尊者も敵わない
サーリプッタそれほど上手じゃないんです
瞑想の場合は阿羅漢なんですけど
知恵第一人者ですけど
ですから まあその方々はまあおそらく二つ持っていたということになります
次に面白いこと アナンダ尊者だけ五つ獲得しているんです
それで終わらないんですよ
お釈迦様がこの大体ではなくて
よく褒めまくるんですよ
このサーリプッタ尊者とアナンダ尊者を
アナンダ尊者はあんまり褒めないんだけど
喧嘩していたんだから
二人で もうまあ 年間も一緒に生活していたんだから
で やっぱり最後にはね
ものすごい言葉で褒めたんですね
サーリプッタ尊者のことをずっと褒めていたんですけど
はい これからそのタイトルを説明していきます
あの ちょっと私は用語を日本語にするのはあまりあのテキストは参考しない
自分勝手な日本語つけるんです
多聞者第一というのは直訳ですね
しかし アナンダ尊者は釈尊が涅槃に入る前に阿羅漢になっていなかったんです
ちょっとトラブっちゃったんです
阿羅漢になっていなかったんです
あるお坊さんがアナンダ尊者はからかったこともあるんですよ
あんたね ずっと時間お釈迦様のそばにいるんだけどね
心は全然上達していないでしょうと
いわゆる偉大なる釈尊から如来から得るべきものを得ていないんだよと
それはアン尊者には言うことはなく黙っていたんですけど
さっさとお釈迦様が割り込んでいて
そんなこと言ってはいかんと
これとっても頭がいい人やと
努力者努力者だよ で 簡単に悟りに達しますよと
瞬間で すっごい早く瞑想したら悟りに達しますよという予言までするんで
あんまり誰に対しても予言しません
しかし 釈尊からタイトルをつもいただいたんですね
そこでアナンダ尊者だけ基本条件そろってないんですよ
阿羅漢になってないんです
なのに称号をもらってるんです
それまで一個だけなくて
五つ 第一番目 パーリ語の単語を同じ言葉を繰り返しますから
一回だけ出します エータダッガン
ビッカリママサーワカーナン
ビックービックーナン
バフスッターナン ヤディダンアーナンダ
エータダッガンというのは
これが最高であると この人は
この上のあれがないという意味で
ママサーワカーナン ビックーナーナ
私の弟子である比丘たちの中で
この人は最高であると
何に最高かというと ヤディダン
アーナンダ アーナンダさん
バフスッターナン 間違った言葉はバフスタですね
見えないな 私も見えない
あ こちらですね バウスタ
それで私が訳したのは
私の弟子たちの中で アナンダが学者として第一なのですということ
学者って意味なんですね
バフスタっていうのは
で 直訳すると多聞者になるんですね
で 現代学者といえばちょっとニュアンスが違いますけど
昔はインドはあまりテキスト文化じゃないんですね
すべて暗記する文化なんです
別に文字がありましたよ
文明はかなり発達していましたし
文字もありましたし 書けるし
計算もあったし 天文学も何でもあるものは全部ありましたけどね
難しい計算数学するんですよ
しかし 認めるのはこの紙で書く
書いて計算する人じゃないんです
すべて頭でやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから他の学問を学ぶ時でも
メモばっかり書いて持っていくことは
もうあんた頭が悪いんだから弟子入りはダメということになるんです
だから暗記してやらなくちゃいけない
そういうことで このテキスト文化ではない
先生から聞く 聞いて覚える
覚えたでも思い返しは意味がないんです
そこは大事なところ 単純に言葉を覚えているだけじゃないんです
それは理解する必要もあります
自分で解説分析する必要もあります
ということは学者なんです
だから学者にそういう学んで知識得る人にとっては
仏教ではバフスという単語を使います
それは仏教だけじゃなくて
もうサンスクリット語にしたっても
インドの言葉ではバフスといえば学者という意味になるんです
たくさん聞いたこと 聞く
聞いたことがある人 というわけで
学者としてサーリプッタ阿難尊者が大事なんです
2番目のタイトル 記憶能力者
サティマンターナン ヤディダンアーナンド
省略しています アーナンダさんがサティマンタであると
仏教実践ではサティは気づきということですね
サティマンタっていうのはサティがある人
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で実践しているサティ気づきの瞑想ですね
だからサティがある人の中でアーナンダ尊者が第1と言うと
どういうことかと まだ悟りにも達してないでしょということになるんですね
しかし この語を記憶能力にも使うんです
サティというのはもう一つ意味がありまして
すごい物事を覚えている
記憶する能力 で この場合はその意味で使っているんです
当然 サティの実践をする人の記憶力が向上します
これは皆様にとってとても朗報なんです
朗報じゃないんですかね
聞きたくないかもわかりませんだけど
サティを実践するとボケないんです
記憶能力どんどんどんどん向上するんです
さらに良いポイントは
この何でもかんでもゴミみたいなどうでもいいことを覚えているわけじゃないんです
いらんことは削除できます
頭からきれいさっぱり
必要な 決して忘れてはならないものはしっかり覚えている
その記憶能力は向上するんです
時々物事を覚えている人々がいますけど
もう全然区別判断しないんですね
何でも何でも覚えておいて
それで後で大変なことになるんですね
頭の中がゴミだらけで
いいものも悪いものも
特に我々は考えるとか
ほとんど無駄なことばっかり考えてるでしょうに
思考そのものが悪くないんですよ
新しいアイディア インスピレーション
いろんなものがもうひらめいてくるならば
思考することはいいことなんですが
我々は思考するとどうなるのかで
精神的に病気になってしまいます
時間がなくなってしまいます
力がなくなってしまいます
生きる力がほとんど浪費してしまいます
それは妄想しているながらなんですね
妄想するためにも いくらかデータを覚えておかなくちゃいけないんです
しかし その場合も ほんのわずかな何かを覚えておいて
好き勝手に妄想を回転していくんです
サティを実践すれば その問題は解決します
妄想はほとんどなくなっていって
役に立つ思考はそれでもなくならないんです
同時に 大事なことを覚えて覚えておく能力も向上するんです
だから 私たちにはそんなに記憶能力がない
思考能力がないと思うならば
サティの実践で ヴィパッサナー瞑想の実践で
そこは補うことはできます
向上することはできます
アーナンダ尊者は生まれつき天才的記憶能力を持っていたんです
アーナンダ尊者の場合は
わざとサティの実践して記憶能力の達人になったわけじゃなくて
生まれつきその能力を持ったんですね
持って生まれたんですね
で テキストではもうどれぐらい一日覚える能力あるのかとか
全部書いてはありますけど
注釈書ではね まあそれはちょっとどうかわかりませんだけど
あまり膨大な量なんですけど
で とにかくお釈迦様は説法すると
全部一回でもうピシンと記録するんですね
頭の中で だから単純に言葉記録することじゃないんです
あのテープレコーダーみたいに
それ一つの知識の的な働きなんです
例えば どんな場所で どんな理由で
どんな人に対してお釈迦様がこれを説いたのかという
その背景とともに覚えておくんですね
それからどんな質問でしたかと
相手がどういうことを知りたかったかと
釈尊がどのようにそれを分析して説明して
どのように結論をつけたのかと
それから最後に結果はどうなったのかというエピソードとともに覚えるんです
それを覚える方法なんです
単純に本を読んで覚えたってもね
だって学生さんはね 英語を勉強するは辞書を暗記するでしょ
しかし英語はできないんです
試験合格するかもしれませんだけど
あれは間違ったやり方なんです
あのシチュエーションで
英語の場合はこのシチュエーションで勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
そういう 試みも日本にはあるんですけど
どうかわかりませんね
結果は で シチュエーションというのは
例えばある一つの単語がどんなシチュエーションで
どんな場面で使うのかと
それで覚えておいて 似ている場面でどこででもこれを使える
シミュレーションしてみる
暗記でダメなんですね
だから アナンダ尊者がそうやってこのシチュエーションで覚えていたんですね
だからそれは相当な能力です
次のタイトル これ  3番目のタイトル
正確者ということ ガティマンターナ
ガティという単語なんですね
これすごい難しい単語なんです
ガティっていうのはいろんな意味で使っていて
普通のパーリ語を少々知っている人なんかは
ものすごくもう大変なことになると思いますよ
辞書を引いてみると ガティ生まれにもガティというし
性格にもガティというし
性格にガチ使うのはそれほどたくさん使っているわけでもないんですね
これは行くという動詞から作るんですね
アガティガティとも言うんですね
他人の気持ちに逆らわない
あの他の弟子たちの性格が悪かったという意味ではありませんとね
性格といってもね じゃあアーナンダ尊者だけ性格が良くて
他の坊さんたちがもうあまりにも頑固でわがままでどうしようもない連中でしたのでしたんでしょうかということじゃないんですよ
みんな出家で阿羅漢の方々でしたから
性格は素晴らしかったんですけど
アーナンダ尊者の場合はそれでもなんか違う性格なんですね
他人の気持ちに逆らわない
適合でき 適合できるなんですね
柔軟性のことですね まあ普通日本語では相性がいいという
よく合うんです みんなに
誰にでも この性格良いだけじゃなくて
もう誰のにもよく適合する
相性が合うという珍しいことなんです
一つの例で言えば このウパーリ尊者という
あの また阿羅漢がいて
戒律の専門家なんですね
だから法律家なんですね
仏教の戒律っていうのはほとんど法律に似ていますからね
だからまあまあいいんじゃないかっていう性格になりませんよ
はっきりと有罪か無罪か
イエスかノーか決めるんです
あの裁判の方々はね この場合はちょっと審判できませんよと
はっきりしませんよと
有罪か無罪か そんな判決ないでしょ
決めなくちゃいけないんです
その場合は俗世間のことだから
曖昧中途半端で明確に有罪だと証明できない場合は無罪にしてしまうんです
しかし 捕まって訴えられたんだから
いくつかの証拠はあるんですよね
だからそんな簡単に無罪にできるかっていう疑問もありますが
やっぱり法律でははっきり白黒しないとダメですから
微妙にでも疑いがあったら
じゃあ無罪にするということになるんです
で そういうこの例なんです
何が例ですかね それで
あのウパーリ尊者の場合は
そういう性格的に法律家だから
誰かが何かちょこちょこと何かもう問題を起こしたりとか
ちょっとだらしないことを言ったり
まあまあまあ そんな程度ではいいんじゃないかっていうことにはなりません
ウパーリ尊者は これが戒律によってこれこれでもうダメですと
だからそういう風にイエスのはっきりすると
誰とも相性が合うっていうわけじゃないんですね
で サーリプッタ尊者に至らば
智慧の第一人者でしょ
それですごい論理的で理性にもとずく
ついて ものすごいしっかりと物事を分析する
心理を分析する だから
ちょっとあんまりこう
頭の悪い方の人々は まああまりサーリプッタ尊者にことを気に入るわけじゃないでしょう
他の方々は大変人格者で立派なもう錚々をせす立派な人格者ですけど
この適合性というところはそれほどなかったんですね
それでアナンダ尊者はもう誰とも仲良し
そういうことでガティマンテ
よい性格であっても 他人に合わない場合は対立が生じますからね
アナンダ尊者とは対立は生じません
アナンダ尊者って仏教歴史上対立になったケースはないんです
サーリプッタ尊者には結構何人かがね
怒っていろんなことを言われた
根拠ないことでね 訴えた
訴えられたこともありますよ
アナンダ尊者に対しては誰にも何も言いませんでしたからね
はい 次 これどう読むんですか？ 勇敢ですか
はい 勇敢 第一 ディティマンターナン
ヤリダンアーナンド ディティマンタという言葉なんですね
理性のあるという意味なんですね
勇敢 血筋の強いという意味もあります
いわゆるしっかりしていますよ
あの前の特色から見れば
なんか中途半端じゃないかなって
それは中途半端というわけじゃなくて
相性がいいだけの話で
しかし 本人がしっかりしている性格なんです
優柔不断の反対ですよ
このディティマンタっていうの
英語で言えばリゾルート
カレイジースというということですね
仏教では智慧 理性 理性と一緒に使う単語です
血筋の強いアーナンダ尊者の実行力は第一でしたんですね
ですから この実行力と理解しても構いませんし
決めたことをやる 優柔不断じゃないんです
勇敢です だから理性にはつながります
ディティの場合は理性という意味もあります
血筋が強いという意味もあります
だから正しいことは理性でなければわからない
それで決めたことはしっかり実行する
すぐに えっと これ何でしたっけ？従者
第一になるんですね ウパッタクアーナン
ヤリダンアーナンド この仏教の中でも皆さんよく知っているのは
アナン尊者従者であったことなんですけど
それは 5番目なんです
本当は本人の そばにいて身の回りのお世話をすることのことにおいては
アーナンダ尊者が第一でした
このなんで 5番目にしたのかっていうと
これはお釈迦様に対してなんですね
だからお釈迦様という個人との関わりで
偉大なるお釈迦様のそばにいる
そばにいてお世話する
それだったらもうアーナンダ尊者には誰もかなわないということでの 5番目の称号なんですね
だからそれ 5番目なんです
前の 4つはすべての人々に関係あるもので
そういうことですごい見事に順番つけてます
釈尊のお世話を時々他の比丘たちも行ったことがあるが
釈尊の気に入りではなかったんです
あんまり相性が合わないんですね
アーナンダ尊者が自分を置いておいて
釈尊のお世話をにかけたんです
人のお世話をすると もう自分のことはもう忘れちゃって
もうかけてやるんです
これも学んだ方がいいんで
私たちにも何か何か頼んだら
まず自分のことを先に出すんですね
私があれがあってこれがあってもうできんとかね
例えば人の看病を夜しなくちゃいけない
そんなこと夜は眠くなりますからとかね
寝なきゃダメでしょうとか
自分のことを先に出しちゃうんです
やっぱりやるべきことがあったら
自分を捨ててやるんですよ
それが仏教が認める生き方なんです
自分のわがままは置いといた方が立派な人間になります
それはしないんだから
結構夫婦関係も壊れるし
子供との関係も壊れるし
もう何でもかんでも壊れてしまいますよ
ブッダに褒められたアナンダ尊者
はい 次にあの涅槃行のところを紹介します
ほぼ 24 年間ぐらい ですね
アナンダ尊者が仕事をしたんです
で お釈迦様は 80歳になって
ちょっと前からずっと付きっきりで
アナンダ尊者もう年でしたけど
すごい健康でしたしね
苦行なんかやったことはないんだからね
お釈迦様とほぼ同じ年だと仏典では書いてますけど
私はどうかなと 自分の個人的な疑問がありますけど
もしかすると年下ではなかったんじゃないかなと
しかし 仏典 ブッダの生涯のことを記録するところでは
アナンダ尊者やら何人か一緒に生まれたんだと
と書くんですから まあわかりません
アナンダ尊者 菩薩が生まれると同時にアナンダ尊者も生まれましたと
となってくると同じ年なんですね
それで 80歳のお釈迦様が体ボロボロで病弱でで苦労していると
アナンダ尊者はお世話すると
同じ 80歳だからね ちょっと話にならないんですけど
しかし すごい健康でしただけは確かなんです
ものすごい長生きしたんです
120歳まで生きていられたというふうに言われているんです
病気一つにならないで
それなら一応わかりますね
日本でもね  80歳なのにすごい元気でいる
何の病気もない方々もいるでしょうに
そこで最後にお釈迦様が結構病弱で
赤痢というね 下痢になったりして
これがもう  2  3ヶ月すらお釈迦様はもう一箇所に閉じ込められたこともありますね
動かなくなって で その時お釈迦様は一応体力があったんだからね
一人でいたんですね 誰もお世話するなよと
で それで自分の力で病気を治して
また表に出て それからはアナンダ尊者のお世話を受けましたけど
まあお釈迦様はもう涅槃に入るともう何回も何回も言うんです
もう体はもたないんだと
これ以上はと 壊れてるんだと
やっと生きてるだけですよと
しかし お釈迦様にはお釈迦様の力っていうのは並ではないんだからね
自分には精神的な力を使えば長生きできますよと
って言うんです それは大げさではなくて
アーナンダ尊者に言うんです
アーナンダ尊者があんまり
まあまあ だってそうでしょうという感じでいるんです
お釈迦様が言うことをあんまり真剣に考えなかったんですね
お釈迦様もはっきり直接
間接直接言わないで 間接的に
言う場合も この日本でよく誤解している
このヴェーサーリが美しいとかね
ヴェーサーリ町 お釈迦様は最後に生きることはなんて美しいでしょうと言ったんだよというだらしない
自分たちの気持ちはお釈迦様にかぶってやろうかなという
日本の学者の方々の これは断言的に間違いなんです
お釈迦様は生きることは素晴らしいことだと一度でも言ったことはないんです
生きることは苦であると言ったんですけど
だからヴェーサーリ町は美しいということで
生きることは素晴らしい
どうやってそれを繋げるんですかね
流寿泉は美しいんだからしょうがないでしょうに
お釈迦様は全部このずっと歩いていた道だから
歩きながら北へ北へ来て歩いていったんですね
最後の旅 戻らないんですね
ご自分で知ってるんです
だから戻らないんだから
この町にさようならというような意味なんですよ
だからまあ 町を展望できるどこかに行って
ああ 美しいですねとか
で 菩提樹にもお釈迦様が挨拶をしたんだからね
助かってくれ 助けてくれたと
私の悟りに達するためには
感謝ですね 感謝しますという意味なんですね
そういうことで ずっと生活して
歩いて 旅に旅をして 一生
で 歳になってくると もう戻っていくんですよ
北へ 生まれた故郷へ で
もうその時はもうそれから終わりですからね
戻らないんだから 美しい巨大な街とか
そういうところには まあ美しいとで一言葉を語ったんです
ラマニーヤンサーラーナンダチェーティヤン
ラマニーヤンヴェーサーリ町とか
ものすごい美しい言葉で
それはパーリ語で読むと
なんかありがとうという意味で取れますけど
ではさようならと それがお釈迦様
生きることはなんて美しいことでしょうかとおっしゃったのではないかとかね
うーん まあ文奈エルとなりますけどもね
そこまで仏教を誤解すると
偉大な学者の方々は それで
アーナンダ尊者大変なんですよ
お釈迦様がもうもう歩けないと言って
もう座りましょうというと
さっさと座るところ用意してあげる
もう横になりますと言っちゃうと
もうすぐ横になるように用意してあげたりして
それである時はもう喉が渇いたんだよと水を飲みたい
で アーナンダ尊者が鉢を持って川に行くと
はい 帰ってきました しかし
川の水がすっごく汚くて
あの車がね 牛車が通って石油を散らじゃうと
泥泥水は病弱なお釈迦様に飲ませませんということで水を持ってこなかったんです
で 水は汚れてるんだ そうしたら
お釈迦様が私は喉が渇いてるんだ
水を飲みたいんです 水持ってきてと頼むんです
はい わかりました とまた行くんです
行っても本人にはあの水を込めないんですよ
これは飲ませませんで
いくらでも また戻るんです
それでお釈迦様はやっぱり山間の水を飲みたいんだと
言うとまた行くんです
それで山間に行ったら
ものすごく澄んだ水が流れているんです
綺麗な水が それでそれを運んで汲んでお釈迦様に飲ませる
で お釈迦様は預言するんですね
悪魔というかね マーラさんがね
もう涅槃に入った方がいいんじゃないんですかと
あんた約束したでしょ？悟った時は
悟った時 私は涅槃に入りなさいと言ったのに
もう終わったんだから
その時はまあ 比丘たち比丘尼たちが悟りに達して
仏教を理解して世に伝える能力がある限り
ない限りは私は涅槃に入りませんよと
で 在家の女性たち男性たちも仏教を学んで理解して
心を清らかにして 次の世代に伝える能力を持っている
それだったら私の仕事は終わりました
その時は悟りに入りますよと
涅槃に入りますよと言ったんじゃないかと言って
悪魔がマーラさんが今あなたの比丘たちが大変立派で悟りに達していて
世に仏教を広げているんだと
他人多宗教と論理的に話し合って対話をして
仏教の真理を正しいと証明している能力はあるんだよと
同じ能力 比丘尼たちにもあるんだよと
男性の方々にも女性の方々にもあるんだよと
もう大したもんやという
悪魔さんが褒めるんですね
で ですからもう涅槃に入られた方がいいんじゃないですかと
そしたらお釈迦様は確かにその通りですと
ですから あんた心配することはないんだと
これから 3ヶ月間で 涅槃に入りますということで
自分の寿命を延ばせる能力をそこで自分で切るんです
そこでまあインドの地面が揺れるんです
地震が起こるんです ものすごい不可思議な現象
たくさん起きたと みんな怯える
すごい音が聞こえている
で それからまあ 世界いきなり明るくなりまして
見えないものまで見えてしまったという不思議な現象
いくつか記録しています
地鳴りがあまりにもひどくて驚いちゃって
アナンダ尊者は何でもお釈迦様に聞くんです
お釈迦様がすごい不可思議な現象が起きましたと
どういうことかといったら
お釈迦様がその時ごく普通にああ
この世の中でね ブッダ菩薩が生まれる時はそういうことが起こるし
涅槃に悟りに達する時もそういうことは起こるし
まあそれから転輪王でしたっけ？転輪王になる人が生まれる時もそういうことが起こるし
で ブッダが寿命をやめた時
寿命の切った時も起こるし
涅槃に入る時も起こりますよという
まあその それから自然現象でも時々そういうものは起こりますよと
言って この場合は自然現象ではありませんと
アナンダ尊者にも考える余地を与えて
ではこれはどういう原因？はっきり言ってないんです
後で考えたら分かった
これがおそらくお釈迦様が自分の寿命の能力を切っちゃったんではないかと
生きる意欲をもうやめたんじゃないかなと驚いちゃって
びっくりして さっさとお釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様はこれを何回もおっしゃったでしょう
私には寿命を延ばせることできるんだと
ですから お願いしますから
人類のために長生きしてください
と言ったら もう遅いんだよと
私はあれほど明確に あれほどもう品のない言葉で
その場合は品のない言葉ということを使っています
だから ウェーサーリ町が美しいということは
何でそれほど日本の学者さんがね
これ日本の学者だけなんですよ
まあ勘違いすることには
もうノーベル賞があればね
もう推薦してあげたいんです
それだけじゃないんだから
日本の勘違いはね 他の学者も言うならば
だからその言葉にお釈迦様は後でオーラーリカというあまり品のない
もう派手あまりにもはっきり言った言葉であると
あれほど言ったのに あんたわからなかったんだよと
だからもう遅いんだと
あと 3ヶ月間だけですと言って宣告するんですね
それでもお釈迦様がもう力切っちゃったんだから
なおさら体が弱くなったんです
で  1日ほんのわずかな距離しか歩かなかったんです
で やっぱり故郷には行けなかったんです
で 途中で横になったんです
それでマッラというところですけどね
インドの旅をするときは
そういう場所は全部あります
で アナンタ尊者にはいてもたってもいられなくなっちゃって
ずっとお釈迦様のそばにいたんですけど
もう顔を見られないんですね
出て行ったんです 出ていて
自分が あるところでドアに手をかけて泣き崩れているんです
でお釈迦様はいつでもアナンダどこ？アナンダどこかとも結構調べる
聞くんだから アナンダはどこどこ行ったのかといったら
もうもうダメですと アナンタ尊者はもう
本当に悲しくて泣いてるんだと
言ったら お釈迦様が呼びなさいよと
そしたら比丘たちが お釈迦様呼んでるんだよと言われたら
一言ではい わかりました
さっさとお釈迦様のところに行くんです
行った時 アナンダ尊者にについて語った言葉なんです
ディーガラッタンコーテアーナンダタタハガトパッチパッティと
あんたはすごい長い時間
長い間如来にお世話しましたよと
メッテーナカーヤカンメーナ
慈しみに基づいた体の行為
手足を動かしてすべて慈しみに溢れていた行為だよと
ヒテーナツケーナ 私のことを考えて
私の幸福を考えて 楽を考えて
私に対してもものすごい無量の慈しみで
あんた行動しましたよと
アッドウェーナ 気持ち 2つはなかったんだと
君には たった一つの気持ちで
アッパマーネーナ  この気持ちの大きさといえば
無量の気持ちで君は私に対して教わっていたんじゃないんですか？と
あまり正しい訳ではないんだけど
この文章を 3つにしているのお釈迦様はわざわざと
あんた このような慈しみに無量の慈しみの気持ちで
言葉で私にお世話しましたと
あんた考える時でも私のことしか考えたことはないんだと
だから身口意の行為 全部そのように無量の慈しみで行ったのではないかと
だから何の問題もないということなんですね
授者としては みじんも文句を言うところはないと
完璧だと あんた 如来に完璧に教わしたのではないかと
その場合はブッダではなくて如来という単語を使うんですよ
だから宇宙で考えて 生命全体で考えて
如来なんです 偉大なる人っていうこと
それからお釈迦様がさらに褒めるんです
カタプンニョーシトアナーナンダ
あんたはとっても徳を積みました
パダーナンマヌンジャキッタンホーヒーシアナースオー
アナンダよ 君は徳を積みました
修行に励んでみなさい
間もなく漏ろというのは直訳ですけど
悟りに達するんだと 心配することはないんだと
ちゃんとちょこっと瞑想していれば
もうそれで悟り達しますよと
それほどもう徳を積んでいるんだと
釈尊は予言を避けますが
この場合はアナンド尊者のために予言をなさるんです
慰めてあげるんです で
なぜかというと アナンド尊者はなんで泣いたのかというと
お釈迦様が涅槃に入るし
私にもいた偉大なるこの仲間というかね
その方がもう一緒にいる方が消えましたと
これから私は誰のそばにいればいいでしょうかと
誰のお世話するんですかと
私はまだ未熟だよと 私は未熟のままでアドバイスまだまだ必要にも関わらず
指導必要にも関わらず
あれやめなさい これやめなさい
あれしなさい これしなさいと言われる身でありながら
偉大な釈尊が涅槃に入るんだということで泣いていたんですね
だから うん あんたはもう十分だよと
もうすぐ瞑想したら もうすぐそれで全部完了するんだよ
気にすることはないと予言するんです
これ お釈迦様の 2回目の予言なの
アナンド尊者に対しての
そこでアナンド尊者が最高の従者であること
比丘たちに報告するんです
次に アナンド尊者の話それでそのまま比丘たちに比丘たちを呼んで話すんです
イエピテビッケアヘスンアティタマッダーナン
アラハントサンマサンブッダ
過去においていた正覚者たち
テーサンバガワンターナンエータパラマーエーワウパッキャカヘスン
その過去のブッダたちにも従者がいたんだよと
しかし この人の基準であると
アナンド尊者の セイエタイマイハンアーナンド
私にもアーナンド どのように従者するのかというと
まるっきりそのレベルでやっていたんだよと
これがもう一番絶対的な高いレベルであると
過去の正覚者にもおられた従者の徳も
このアーナンドの徳と同じくらいである
これが最高位となるのですと
これ以上できませんよと
お世話は アナンド尊者より優れたお世話した従者がいたかというと
それはいませんでしたと
過去のブッダたちの間でも
それぐらい最高でしたと
で 将来に現れるブッダたちの従者たちが現れますよと
しかし 彼らはアナンド尊者に勝てるのかというと勝てません
アナンド尊者は最高位でもうやっているんだから
誰でもそのレベルだよと
これ 将来のブッダたちに対しても同じ言葉で使っているんです
将来に現れる正覚者たちの従者たちも
あの私の従者のアーナンドと同意になる
これが最高最高位ですと
それほど褒められることできるのかと
過去現在未来にわたって
あんたは最高だよと言えるのはブッダだけなんです
我々には過去現在未来も知らないし
周りのことしか見られませんだから
アーナンダ尊者の資格は超えられないという意味ですね
はい それでそのポイント終わり